how many times have Democrats and their
presto DS declared that Trump's
presidency was on the ropes it seems
like every other day self-righteous
anchors with very serious faces tout a
fictitious White House in crisis story
and this fake news runs the gamut from
the trivial well the president's angry
and isolated his staff is miserable to
the more serious
you can't fire call me for the wrong
reasons
you can't fire him to stop an
investigation I think this is a crisis
for the country blah blah blah it's
always the beginning of the end now
remember the dire predictions about Don
juniors meeting and the Trump Tower with
a Russian lawyer he should be concerned
even more so than he should be concerned
for himself these Donald Trump jr. does
have some legal exposure here and I
think they're shocked that the noose is
tightening that people might go to jail
you're exactly right that's their lives
the noose is tightening one of my
favorites was the frenzy surrounding the
prospect that the Trump presidency
hinged on the words of his former
attorney Michael Cohen if this Michael
Cohen evidence stands up if Michael
Cohen does testify to this this is
potentially huge this is potentially
something that can prove the president
colluded and that isn't that is an
impeachable offense go max headroom and
who could forget the goofballs
predicting that a story peddled by a
porn star would topple Trump if stormy
Daniels comes out that and it seems to
be credible that in and of itself would
bring down this presidency o'donneii of
course throughout all of it was the
media's massive heart pounding build-up
of the Muller probe we're seeing that
the collusion piece of this piece by
piece starting to be built out the
president does look like someone who is
increasingly desperate and the crisis
cliches never stop it feels like we are
finally at a tipping point the walls are
closing in on president Trump but always
wrong never in doubt and never a
correction or a Maricopa their goal from
one has been to drive Trump out of
office the facts be damned and in the
past 48 hours the get Trump gang did
their hype and hyperbole act all over
again
now first was the news of the State
Department oh geez urgent meeting with
House lawmakers Wiley coyote was finally
gonna catch the roadrunner that means
that something is in those documents
that he thinks it's really important
that the people who are doing this
impeachment inquiry see immediately
immediately this is really important or
not so much I don't really know the
relevance of it at a certain point it's
hard to follow there's nothing in here
I think that's directly relevant to the
president's Imperial conduct
drat at first you don't succeed hype
hype again Democrats were salivating on
air and off about today's testimony by
Kurt Volker they thought his resignation
which was forced as Ukraine on net envoy
will met the meeting somehow on Capitol
Hill would be a blockbuster instead it
was another dud has said nothing that
nothing that coincides with what the
Democrats are saying with their whole
impeachment narratives ambassador
Volcker unbelievably knowledgeable about
what was going on in Ukraine as for
impeachment himself mister impeachment
Adam Schiff he seemed today oddly quiet
[Music]
he has comments about comments you can't
stop him from talking suddenly today cat
had his tongue now this would be funny
if it weren't so serious Democrats are
doing the equivalent day after day of
yelling fire in a crowded theater and
that theater is America this is doing
enormous damage to the country and as
for the press
they lost their credibility a long time
ago not sure they can go any lower but
they're trying all the president needs
to do now is smile and keep delivering
results and watch the hype and hyperbole
machine self combust and that's the
angle